[Música]
y en directo vamos hasta el salvador
para discutir con andrés suárez
jaramillo nuestro corresponsal en
centroamérica sobre el revuelo causado
por el presidente nayib ukelele al
anunciar que se postularía para un nuevo
mandato pese a que la constitución
prohíbe la reelección inmediata de los
mandatarios sin embargo un fallo de la
sala de lo constitucional de la corte
suprema en 2021 le abrió la puerta a
bukele para ser candidato andrés muy
buenas noches cuéntenos qué dice
exactamente tanto el fallo de la corte
que habilita a bukele para ser candidato
como la constitución que se lo prohíbe
hola andrés muy buenas noches pues
vayamos directamente a ese artículo 152
de la constitución de el salvador
párrafo 1 y quiero citarlo textualmente
dice no podrán ser candidatos a la
presidencia de la república quienes
hayan desempeñado el cargo de presidente
de la república por más de seis meses
consecutivos o no durante el período
anterior o dentro de los últimos seis
meses anteriores al inicio del periodo
presidencial pues este fue el artículo
de la constitución del salvador que fue
modificado como usted muy bien le decía
exactamente hace un año en septiembre de
2021 por los magistrados de la sala de
lo constitucional de la corte suprema de
justicia magistrados que habrían sido
elegidos por la alianza oficialista de
nadie bukele y lo que hay
bien estamos teniendo problemas de
comunicación y de conexión con nuestro
corresponsal
andrés suárez jaramillo pero ya
retomamos mi forma el tipo de producción
que lo tenemos nuevamente andrés nos
estaba contando sobre qué dice
exactamente el fallo de la corte
el reto como dice este fallo que no
pueden ser candidatos a la presidencia
de la república el presidente las
personas que hayan ejercido la
presidencia por un periodo de seis meses
consecutivos o no o que por ejemplo no
hayan estado no hayan sido presidentes
en los últimos seis meses de de cara al
siguiente turno presidencial esto es lo
que pretende hacer nadie bukle es decir
que antes de que se termine el periodo
presidencial el primero de junio del
2024 él estaría renunciando félix ulloa
que sería su vicepresidente tomaría las
riendas del poder y esta sería la medida
la resolución por la cual él estaría
modificando en la constitución el mismo
libreto que ocurrió por ejemplo con
daniel ortega en nicaragua o con juan
orlando hernández en en honduras y de
esta manera ahora él tendría la
posibilidad de no solo estar cinco años
sino diez del 2019 al 2029